e qual é a história que te inspira ou
melhor quem é o líder que te inspira
e isso me fez voltar os meus 15 anos lá
em Catanduva no interior de São Paulo
e naquela época o domingo era o melhor
dia da semana onde eu gastava quase todo
meu dinheiro na banca do Vicente
comprando revistas em quadrinhos
e as revistas eram o nosso passaporte
para outros mundos cheios de personagens
e aventuras fantásticas
o e entre tantos personagens passando
pelo Batman o homem-aranha até o Hulk
Mulher Maravilha
é um me chamava atenção
eu quero sai clips do x-men
e ele me chamava atenção não por ser o
mais poderoso do grupo pelo contrário
bem por ser um mutante ou o poder o raio
que saia dos seus olhos mas mesmo
criança me entregava o fato de Um Herói
aparentemente franzino sem grandes
atributos físicos sou grande
superpoderes liderar um grupo de heróis
tão Poderoso o icônico e liderança nesse
caso vinha acompanhada de vários
desafios
e já que gerir um grupo de heróis que
estava lidando com preconceitos
entendendo os seus poderes e ajudar a
humanidade não era um desafio fácil
eu vou passar do tempo e lendo as
histórias o site Ops me ajudou a
entender que liderança é sobre serviço
humildade resiliência confiança e
inspiração
e como em uma das principais Sagas do
grupo acima onde o sai para preciso
x-men tinham que escolher entre fugir ou
ficar e lutar isso provavelmente
significaria a extinção da raça mutante
naquele momento
e o site O presentão toma difícil
decisão de se sacrificar e sacrificar a
todos em busca da Vitória
eu vou fazer uma reflexão sobre a sua
liderança nas palavras dele ele disse
e é por isso que eu sou o líder o cego
liderando os egos mas mesmo assim
Obrigada
e o líder porque eu estou preparado para
queda e um líder porque eu estou
preparado para tomar as decisões
difíceis
é porque todo Líder sabe que não é
difícil se sacrificar pelas suas pessoas
O difícil é pedir que suas pessoas se
sacrificam por você ou por uma causa
Oi e para liderar com a certeza de um
futuro incerto não é preciso poder ver é
preciso ter visão é preciso segurar e
não importa o que acontecer não soltar
e o mais legal é quando eu me preparava
para excited eu encontrei outros
exemplos de líderes e histórias que os
inspiraram também
e como ela umansky criador da Tesla
spacex IP e call
a woman's que disse se inspirar nas
Histórias Fantásticas da franquia Senhor
dos Anéis para sua liderança e as coisas
que ele criou
e o Mark Zuckerberg cofundador do
Facebook que disse se inspirar no filme
Ender's Game para criar toda a sua
plataforma de tecnologia e Até Um
Bilionário econômico chinês Jackman
disse se inspirar no seu livro preferido
Ali Babá e os 40 ladrões para criar todo
o seu império
tô vendo tudo isso eu comecei a pensar
no Poder da influência das histórias e
dos grandes líderes nas pessoas
Oi hoje talvez a gente esteja vivendo o
pior momento para diversas gerações
e os líderes da vida real mudaram muito
e em uma recente pesquisa aí é do
Monstros barometer que mede o nível de
reputação e confiança nas organizações
apontou uma séria crise de confiança da
liderança sobretudo as políticas
E isso se agrava pelo fato
principalmente das lideranças políticas
têm dificuldade em lidar com a pandemia
O Outro fator que torna a situação ainda
mais difícil é a tecnologia se por um
lado a digitalização deixou a informação
mais acessível ela também transformou os
líderes em mais vulneráveis e expostos
em
e ainda me arruma outra pesquisa
conduzida recentemente pela Oracle aqui
no Brasil de Maio do final de 2019
apontou que quase oitenta por cento dos
brasileiros confia mais em robôs do que
nos seus gerentes e outra sete em cada
dez profissionais dizem não confiar no
seu chefe direto agora para mim o pior
dado vende uma outra pesquisa Awards
velho serve que é uma pesquisa que mede
a confiança das pessoas umas nas outras
Oi e o Brasil tem o pior score no
ranking desta pesquisa na Noruega por
exemplo setenta por cento dos
noruegueses dizem confiar em uns uns nos
outros e no Brasil esse número é de
apenas cinco por cento e
é mas mesmo que existe uma crise de
confiança na liderança o que me preocupa
é com o fato de mesmo com todos os
problemas que estamos vivendo deixarmos
de sonhar e nos inspirar
e eu estou na net Company desde 2013
quando fundamos a ccxp que é o maior
festival de Cultura pop do mundo
a ser uma empresa caminhonete Oriente
fazer parte dessa grande comunidade é um
grande privilégio e nós encaramos a
responsabilidade do trabalho de melhorar
a vida das pessoas através do
entretenimento dar um motivo para ela
sonhar em escapar em das suas rotinas e
ter em um momento de alegria no seu dia
a dia
uma das melhores experiências que
criamos paixão sonhos e emoção são os
combustíveis que nos movem
Oi e para ilustrar o que eu tô falando
eu separei algumas histórias de pessoas
muito especiais para compartilhar com
vocês
e veja a história desse fã o Paulo
Machado
e o Paulo foi diagnosticado muito
criança com poliomielite e por 51 anos
Ele viveu no Hospital das Clínicas
ajudado e auxiliado por equipamentos de
respiração artificial
e o Paulo mesmo vivendo preso a uma maca
encontrava nos filmes dos quadrinhos e
dos Games a sua alegria de viver
e em uma edição recente e ele nunca
deixou de faltar em nenhuma edição da
ccxp mesmo nessa situação
e ir entrava empurrado pelos seus
Enfermeiros em sua marca dentro de um
dos painéis e ele foi aplaudido de pé
por milhares de pessoas uma das frases
que ele sempre dizia era que vale muito
a pena viver ela nos inspirou aí nos
inspirem tudo que a gente faz até hoje
e no Staff até o público final milhões
de pessoas que são impactados eu vejo o
poder da inspiração
e numa outra história de um outro fã
Hugo Gomes na ccxp 2017 único Hugo
passou 16 horas na fila para entrar nos
painéis da Marvel Studios 1
e em um desses painéis o chefão da
Marvel Kevin feige contava e comentava e
apresentava em primeira mão os próximos
lançamentos dos estúdios para os fãs
como o Capitão Marvel Thor entre outras
e no meio do painel de forma
surpreendente ele faz um grande anúncio
dizendo que o primeiro fã da fila havia
ganho uma passagem com tudo pago para
Los Angeles para acompanhar a Premiere
do filme Pantera Negra ao lado dele dos
atores e diretores do filme O Hugo foi
ao delírio naquele momento e celebrou
com milhares de pessoas que estavam
acompanhando os painéis junto com ele
e mais o melhor da história não é isso o
melhor da história veio depois a
os dias depois ele estava se preparando
para viagem e a nossa equipe entrou em
contato com ele para combinar os
detalhes e oferecer para ele a
possibilidade de levar um acompanhante
nessa aventura eo nos deu uma grande
lição de empatia e humildade ele poderia
escolher qualquer um um amigo um parente
o que seja
É mas o Hugo acabou escolhendo a segunda
pessoa da fila alguém que ele não
conhecia antes que havia chegado apenas
poucos segundos depois dele para entrar
na fila eles se conectaram ali se
conheceram ali viveram aquele momento
juntos e dividiram a mesma paixão
E se o site O que me inspirou milhares
de jovens e crianças são inspirados por
histórias e personagens todos os dias
é difícil não lembrar da história do
menino americano bleacher Warner de
apenas 6 anos
e o brilho ano passado salvou a vida da
sua irmã afastando ela de um ataque de
um cachorro mesmo sendo seriamente
ferido e tomando mais de 90 pontos no
rosto objeto que teve um ato de extrema
bravura e coragem se justificou dizendo
e eu achei que se alguém tivesse que
morrer deveria ser eu
e o menino que é fã das histórias do
grupo de heróis Vingadores recebeu
mensagens de apoio de milhares de
pessoas do mundo
bom e melhor inclusive dos seus maiores
Ídolos
tô vendo tudo isso e se está difícil
sonhar eu digo olhando esses exemplos
que vale muito a pena
Oi e a cultura geek me ensina isso a
todo dia
a liderança é sobre sonhos histórias e
inspiração EA que eu faço uma reflexão
para todos nós
a todos somos líderes de alguma forma de
outra nas nossas casas no trabalho em
outras atividades enfim
E por que não começamos por nós mesmos
nos esforçando para tornarmos para nos
tornarmos essas pessoas que inspiram
e afinal toda vida é uma narrativa e nós
temos a chance de escolhemos viver boas
histórias
e agora eu peço para vocês pararem um
minuto comigo e pensar em
a todos nós ouvimos que a pandemia vai
nos transformar em pessoas melhores
e pode até parecer clichê mas mesmo
quando sai que eu preciso x-men
enfrentavam desafios Apocalípticos ele
sempre se união e voltavam mais fortes
Hum será que nós como seres humanos
faremos igual
e se está difícil confiar no chefe nas
pessoas no próximo ou até nos políticos
eu faço uma pergunta para vocês
e quem são os heróis de hoje ou melhor
em que as nossas gerações do Futuro
estão se inspirando
o outro dia meu filho de 9 anos o
Francisco chegou para mim e disse pai
é o limite não existe apenas se você
deixar ele existir
Aí eu disse para ele nossa com quem que
você aprendeu isso ele falou com o Goku
de Dragon Ball
Tô vendo que meu filho me disse eu vejo
o futuro promissor se há mais de 20 anos
o cyclops me inspirou e até hoje eu
consigo lembrar da força da liderança
dele
e o que as histórias estão fazendo Pelas
nossas novas gerações elas continuam
atuando
Como afinar o que queremos é que bons
exemplos continuem inspirando o nosso
futuro
e o estão ali tem uma frase muito legal
que ilustra O que é ser um super-herói e
ele diz assim a pessoa que ajuda o
próximo porque tem que ser feito e a
coisa certa a fazer
Esse é um super-herói de verdade
Oi e aí já despertou seu Super Poder
em busca inspiração obrigado a